[Music]
girl tell them it was a prank now
please
my name is jennifer lauren arsenault i'm
a licensed marriage and family therapist
and i've been working in the field of
mental health for over 10 years i'm
really excited to see what these couples
have in store for me
so let's get started let's check out
some tic-tacs
oh oh honey that's so unfortunate when
these
artificial milestones or holidays
create real-life relationship
expectations
that's so sweet she's really thoughtful
hope she's doing this based in just her
own desire
and not a last-ditch effort to try to
win him back this is a lot of work
um i can tell she has some genuine hope
and feelings there
long distance is difficult i know it
created a lot of barriers doing
lockdown and quarantine when you're not
even able to see each other
as much as you typically would i hope
that she's
out of place now at this point you know
a couple of months out
either they're back together maybe
yesterday
okay he's aware of what's going on in
her life outside of their relationship
workday stress pedicures that's a good
idea
oh oh she's splurging with the fast food
okay guess what the beauty
and cosmetic purchases hope she up to
annie a little bit
he's serious he's trying to brighten
your day girl
that yesterday movie was cute but i
think it is you know we're saying just
to be
open to what our partner wants what will
make them happy
that's a nice break from the norm this
was nice to see
i'm so sorry
i'm really sorry
was that your spit i sneezed
[Music]
you're spit off me right now please i'm
sorry
okay you're sorry but can you take off
i'm sorry can you take it off sorry i'm
not touching now
what do you mean i'm sorry love i'm not
touching it
that's your problem
[Music]
are you getting
if this was a real incident you know it
would have been the proper thing
to do to at least you know wipe
off this bit yes we can't just apologize
with words sometimes we also need some
action steps
i really enjoyed all of these tic tac
videos
it's so interesting to see how you know
real life things that come up in my
sessions um are playing out in this
hilarious way it also highlighted how
important that is
as a factor in regards to healthy and
happy relationships
[Music]
you